the coolest thing I've ever seen we ran
a seven-on-seven this summer it was our
guys versus our alumni and our alumni
consisted of USC Tennessee UConn West
Virginia Syracuse and we're lined up
playing these guys and I'm just kind of
sitting there laughing going you know
this is ridiculous
I'm a football coach so they don't come
to meet on Shakespeare right I want you
to compete so many Division one
prospects on there you know most teams
are happy to have three they have seems
like thirty we've been called a football
factory this morning DISA game is
basically way of life
tucked away in an industrial park in
Elkton Maryland his high school's newest
football powerhouse Eastern Christian
Academy has 52 students all 52 are on
the football team
David sills the fourth a real estate
developer started Eastern Christian only
three years ago our focus is God first
academic second and football third but
it's really not a huge separation if
Christianity and the school is a ten
that academics is nine point nine and
footballs and nine point eight Davis
vision was to create a program that
would get kids closer to Christ teach
them how to compete at a high level not
only on the field of play but in the
classroom and in life and get young
people to college if you think that
we're football factories sit down with
us and we'll explain to you the entire
program I would consider Eastern
Christian Academy of Football Factory
but that's not a bad thing these young
men are going there to further their
opportunity to play college football so
we we did the job for 20 minutes David's
son David v is a former quarterback
prodigy who gained national attention as
a 13 year old when he was offered a
scholarship from USC
this led to questions about why he
started Eastern Christian did he do it
just to surround his son with top
football talent I can't stop an opinion
from somebody saying you know you
started to school for your kid okay
would I have started the school if I
didn't have a kid that didn't play
football probably not I mean that was
maybe a precipitating factor to having
the school but as I've said many many
times I could have sent him anywhere I
started the school for the other kids
this is his ministry this is what he
wants to do the vision was to get kids
to college and
get kids closer to Christ and that's
still division and that will always be
division the kids that we help our kids
that are mostly at-risk kids that won't
be able to afford college many of the
kids from Eastern Christian come from
Wilmington Delaware in the surrounding
New Castle County Wilmington is known as
one of the most dangerous small cities
in America it's a lot of bad stuff that
goes on drug-dealing
killings robberies everything I mean I
mean that's everywhere though does it
not and on a typical day you see people
getting shot cops everywhere and just
like spit that's the place you don't
want to be right over here you come down
here this probably one of the roughest
spots probably in this little this
little area if you take you walking down
here just I kind of don't once I'll walk
you down there it's a little rough
really what we're trying to do is get
kids noticed from an athletic
perspective
Eastern Christian recruits many of its
players using flash training an intense
workout program led by head coach Duane
Thomas you have no idea you have no idea
my first one about Eastern Christian
Academy after my youth career I started
working out with flash training and I
got to meet some of the coaches and they
came to my my little league games and
they just watched me play and started
talking about if I was interested in
coming or school if you go to flash
training with Dwayne Thomas and you're
with him for more than two days you want
to be with him forever get right on the
field get right in the box you're going
right the special to you today on what
to do that we have very similar kids
seems like from very similar backgrounds
the biggest difference is we have to
take everybody that's here that's all we
get select from we don't have an
opportunity to say hey you can come here
and we can help you this is our wall all
the alumni of ECA that are all playing
college football that's an advantage
that they have specially to good athlete
you know that's you know way to kind of
boost you talent on your team
Jameer a defensive back at Mississippi
State was one of those talented Eastern
Christian players who came out of
Wilmington he was a cover corner in your
face physical corner that could run with
the best receivers in the country coming
out of high school he was a tough kid or
I can go through some of the things he's
been through while at his youth football
game Jameer learned that his mother had
been murdered his coach Chris Parnell
broke the news to Jamir it was tough man
because you know how do you let a 12 13
year old know you know something
dramatically just happened to their
mother so we can't let him know hey your
mom's been shot it's been something's
happened so after that we got it done
you had to go back to my house and it
was crazy he was a bunch of cops
everywhere I was still in my football
uniform I was like what is going on this
can't be real and just people kept
asking me questions and I was just
confused he was only in the eighth grade
he had to go into witness protection
program the police thought my life was
in danger so they decided to move me
somewhere else for a while
Jameer spent a year in North Carolina
before coming back to Wilmington to live
with his grandfather
it was after his return when he first
met David sills the first time I met
Jameer was it was that flash training it
actually was on the day that his brother
was killed in a house fire you know
Jameer was down there he's a little shy
you know he had just gotten back it
wasn't too long since he had gotten back
from North Carolina and I think he got
home that night
brother had been killed it was it was
horrible Jameer had already suffered
more tragedy than most teenagers
unfortunately for him there was more to
come we sent him off one day to a
combine he ended up winning the combine
came home and you know his grandfather
had died everything was just so much to
handle and I just didn't want to deal
with anything at that time
you know I give him a lot of credit
because he's a lot stronger of a person
than I am I just don't know if I'd be
able to go go through with you know what
he's been through and everything like
that and just still be able to still be
able to drive forward and move on and
and really be successful as the way he
is now when I go back to ECA
and I and I know know the kids I stare
at us that are going through some of the
same stuff I went through with what
probably their family or just being out
in the neighborhoods and stuff like that
I try to give them encouragement they
they look up to me I want to be in my
position so I let them know that uh if
you want to be the best and this this is
where it's at you can't run the streets
and go to school you know you got to
pick one or the other he comes from the
same community as me and just in a
person like that make it and play and
he's just like us
shows me that I can do the same thing I
always thank God for you because of his
grace given you in Christ Jesus or in
him you have been enriched in every way
and all your speaking and all your
knowledge we do things I think at a
college type level athletically so we're
trying to train them to be the best that
they possibly can in football so we take
their competitive spirit put it in the
classroom
now they're competing for A's and B's
you had a plan putting together a
program that will prepare kids for
college I wanted their day to be similar
to a college workday from the academic
day to study all strengths the condition
into practice the virtual in virtual
powerhouse comes from the curriculum
students follow people did not
understand the online curriculum we're
at football games and they're chanting
where's your textbooks
although Eastern Christian has two
on-site academic coaches the curriculum
is provided by a separate online private
school you might want to say that we're
a little ahead of the curve but if you
look at most colleges they're forcing
you to take online classes our kids take
online classes all day every day
the line between student and athlete is
a thin one as they transition from
school work to football seamlessly
the fact is it's only one thing that
cures and athletes hunger and that's
work it's really in the back of their
minds the focus on football throughout
the day so many times we're walking
around and seeing huddle up or seeing
videos up all right when Coach boom
asked how many of you to watch the game
he was referring to on your own time at
home okay
not in here where you're supposed to be
doing schoolwork you know this is what
they do this is who they are they're
football players but they're also
students they're also Christians and so
we try to break it up
lunch all right we talked about this
yesterday lunch will be a little bit
shorter all right we're gonna have about
a half an hour of your time and then
offense will be in here to watch film
defense will go outside and do a walk
work it's typically right out the front
door into the parking lot which is
actually not uncommon for a lot of
colleges
so do that it's different because in the
other school it's just like it's like an
extra activity here it's like the main
focus you you nearly feel about yourself
where everybody does come see you step
up in there and make those dark our
place
with no home field to call their own and
most of their games played out-of-state
the Eastern Christian students get one
more college like experience most of our
away games are overnight trips for the
difficulty finding regional games at
times we will typically leave Thursday
at like 10 p.m. 11 p.m. depending on how
far we're going then we get on the bus
and basically we sleep and drive all
through the night to get where we're
gonna go we've been able to get
ourselves a great schedule yearly over
the last two years people wanted to
compete against us and giving us an
opportunity to compete against them
we've competed against some of the best
programs in the country
we know that colleges are going to
recognize those teams and say okay well
hey you can do that against them you
know that that gives the kids a lot more
opportunity to be exposed to big
colleges even though it's not all about
football part of the vision is to win
football games
that is important if we win football
games we play the hardest schedule and
we compete with these teams
that's our vehicle to get people answer
the doors the guard block Paul you
attack in there that guy go blocks my
back the system we got to follow the
system any reason to come Eastern
Christian was football because of the
fact of the circumstances that I was in
that I honestly could see myself going
to college were all football Shamar
Hardin is a junior offensive lineman who
has already received interest from
several Division one programs when I
first met him more he was very
Slippery I would say you know we would
talk about you know future and you know
he would make commitments and dates to
go work out and do things and he would
always slip I was going slow light came
on for him in the ninth grade where he
decided that you know his future was
important to him and so he got into the
fold and when I'll tell you when he
jumped in he jumped in with both feet
and he's been a very committed person
you know he works hard I think that's
that's one of his motivation is just to
help his mom out just kind of been my
Road dog throughout life we can't go too
long without seeing talking to each
other
my mom mean so much I love my mom so
much I would do I would do anything for
my mom my mom or like we're like best
friends because in the community where
you know people are shot and killed on a
daily basis doesn't have to be so much
of what's going on in the home as to
what's going on outside the home I try
to allow my kids to know that we don't
live out there we live in here so I keep
them grounded with what goes on inside
my house and alone no involvement out
there like that he's not a victim of
what's going on around him he's been
more an exception to he's gonna say you
know what this is what's happening
around me but it doesn't have to have to
happen to me I mean it's definitely
important for me to get my feeling the
different here I can't I can't I can't
have my mom living here for too much
longer I don't like having my mom like I
don't like my mom being in this
situation the best way to get out of
and I do like I do the best thing the
best thing for me to do is to play
football type characters thing out as
far as I can without is that Christian
no Shamar would not be where he is today
he would not have had the exposure I'm
probably the only one that's gonna come
out of here a lot of people don't make
it out here
what do you want in life do you want to
go to a football factory or do you want
to go to a normal school maybe you come
from an or --ml school where it's not
advantageous for your goals to stay
there so you go to a place like Eastern
Christian Academy
not everyone's doubt the same hand you
got to do what's best for you if you're
an athlete it's training it's working
with you all the things that take for
you to be a great athlete and all it
doesn't matter what sport you're playing
so the vision of the school is to
eventually grow into as many sports as
we have kids that are interested in we
have a program to infiltrate the entire
United States over time with I think we
had 12 schools per area and 26 areas so
it became a you know massive undertaking
I don't think it'll happen in my
lifetime but it's mapped out and ready
to go
David sells v will play football at West
Virginia University in the fall he broke
his ankle in the third game of the
season and the team finished three and
nine
we have you show me business so we got
to show each other today that we've
taken another step for the ultimate goal
you can ask me Jim
shemar has received offers from Boston
College temple and Buffalo after his
grandfather died
Jameer lived with the SILS family who
later became his Guardians he legally
changed his name to Jamir Irvin sills
and David sills is confident in his
blueprint for Eastern Christian Academy
the things that we see that God does on
behalf of Eastern Christian and these
kids on an absolutely everyday basis
only proves one thing that our faith is
well-placed and you know that God is
doing great things for us and that we've
got to keep on pushing ahead for him